thank you so much for watching all our
videos reading all our blogs and
listening to our podcasts we quite
literally wouldn't be here without you
thanks I just want to thank all of our
viewers and listeners for engaging with
our content it's only possible because
of all of you so thank you so much you
like us you really
well so much for letting us be part of
your developer Journey it has been an
inspiration to see what you've built and
we can't wait to see what you build next
thank you so much Google Cloud fam for
the views the likes the comments the
shares we could not keep doing what we
love and helping you out on your Cloud
Journey without you so let's keep our
heads in the cloud thank you so much for
being here with us and for helping us
grow
seriously without all of you this would
not be possible so from the bottom of my
heart thank you hey you Cloud friends
thank you so much for showing all the
love and support that you have been
showing by engaging with the content
that we've been producing I would like
to know what would help make your Google
Cloud Journey better let us know thank
you so much for being with us on this
crazy and weird Journey with the puns
and the dad jokes and the excessive
amount of snacks we could not have done
it without you thanks thank you so much
thanks for learning with us gracias
thank you so much for all of your
support over these years and we're
really excited to show you what comes
next
thank you